so you were there from the very
beginning i was i was there uh one of
the lifers i'm a i i was a conan lifer i
started
working on the show well i worked with
conan at snl ah
when he was a writer there
and that's interesting i didn't know
that the writers would interact with the
music booker well
when conan started
i had that experience that i think a lot
of people do with him
i remember going home and telling my
wife like i met a guy today who's like
maybe one of the funniest people i've
ever met
which i know sounds crazy but
he like i don't know that's true not
that i spent that much time with him but
we definitely connected it's not like we
became best friends but you know at snl
especially for a young a new writer like
that when you would identify someone who
was sort of nice and supportive and you
know and a good laugher a good laugher
yeah
oh my god you get a pair of handcuffs he
was like i got a live one yeah yeah so
we
so and of course michael worked at at
snl uh so robert smith robert and i
worked together
my entire time
at snl uh you know we were we were pals
and uh got to know conan a little bit
and so when
the opportunity came up
um
and so each season like the year after i
started i got a job in the talent
department and then the next season
i
became a talent coordinator and just
sort of worked my way up to music
booking right which is what i did the
last few years i was there
and so
you know when letterman was leaving it
was obviously a huge deal
you know we all know the story obviously
right he was leaving nbc leaving nbc and
they were and lauren was given the hour
to and to find you know given the 12 30
show charged with picking letterman's
replacement i'm assuming that everybody
read bill carter
anyway when he chose conan
i was
thrilled because for conan and knowing
that robert was involved and i knew that
jeff ross was going to be involved and i
knew jeff a little bit
so
i saw that as an opportunity to do
something musically or a to be part of a
cool startup and yeah were you like i
don't know how much longer snl is going
to last i know
listen i did the calculus and i think
yeah
there's no way it could go beyond 95.
yeah yeah no but no the the uh the
second element was that music wise i
always thought the 12th or like the
latter on the letterman show they were
able to do a much more varied lineup you
know
snl had to be a big big big in terms of
the musical acts yeah and what appealed
to me was
you know doing stuff
that was sort of all over the map and a
little more eclectic and um so finding
new talent yeah so conan they did a
press conference at the um his opening
press conference was at the rainbow room
where he was introduced and i i ran into
he and smile up there and said hey you
know i'd love to be a part of this show
and you know one thing led to another
just happened to be dancing up there
that was a fortuitous uh moment i guess
it was and then and you know i spoke to
lauren and he sort of gave his blessing
for me to to change shows and so i was
part of the first i mean i
paula davis myself who's a head talented
talent producer yeah there were only a
handful of us but we were there i would
say and like the show went on in
september we were there in like july
yeah for the startup were you like well
the show's coming on in september it's
july
i'll get around to looking at bands like
you know late august
there's no rush kona requested the first
guest that was on well
yes i mean he has distilled it down to
like they told me i could have whoever i
want i mean it was
in a way within reason yeah yeah yeah
sure
cohen all that summer while we were in
the office
it's it's sort of a well-known story now
but he as he always does walked around
with his guitar but the song that he was
more obsessed with than any was creep
sure so that was 1993
and i remember him doing that in
2021
last week right right so he's been doing
it for 30 years and still hasn't
improved
and you know you have to remember they
weren't yet radiohead right you know
they were they were another was that the
year their first album came out creep
was the single was the current single
wow yeah so and yes it's when that album
came out so
i you know went right out to capitol
records and said hey you know
everyone's aware of the new show and
like hey we'd love for them to be the
first music guest and uh
and so it wasn't really a huge get at
the time i mean yes they had a big hit
and cohen loved it right but they just
as easily could have been it could have
been a one hit one
you know urge overkill or one you know
the breeders
you know any other band that we had on
in those weeks you know but of course
yeah in retrospect it looks genius and
it's it's awesome i love it i love it i
mean it's it's just a great uh it's a
great legacy and a great it was a great
kickoff for music on the show and it
yeah and conan loved it so did conan try
to play creep with them on the show did
he want to do that no
no
you know i don't know if you swings you
remember probably jesse i don't know if
you've watched many of the old music
clips or remember them from when they
aired but the first year on the show one
of conan and robert's ideas was to have
footage
like stock footage playing on a screen
behind the bands
right
just non-sequitur
ridiculous you know
and was it like a menu that the bands
could choose from yes
we gave them our film researcher i don't
recall who it was at the time but right
would give us gave us a list of hearings
you know and so i remember when you do
karaoke and there's always just sort of
exactly
so we took random stock footage yeah we
took radiohead up to the ninth floor
conference room and um
you know showed them
a few of the different options and they
chose
cars driving around in circles very slow
like in slow motion and so
that's what appears behind them
on their first conan appearance